I started everybody started are we all here yeah hello hello
everybody hello hello Ditto was sleeping that's you I was
not sleeping I just I just yeah what were you yeah you were
just late well why were you late yeah why were you late I
took a nap just last night she missed her alarm guys she
missed her she missed her alarm she slept through her alarm
but I came here okay we're all here I did very good we're
all here now alright why don't we all introduce ourselves
who wants to start does anyone want to start oh I'll start
okay hello my I am I am a Doki bird.
Hello.
Okay, I'm right.
I'm done Thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah I accidentally sent my tomato picture to to Hiyodo
and Na-chan and they were like is this is this Doki?
And I was like, yeah
Hey, who wants to go next?
Who wants to go next?
Okay, I can go next Okay.
Hi, I'm hero.
Hero, hero, hero.
Yeah.
That's it.
Nice to meet you.
Yeah, of course.
Thank you.
All right.
Yeah, I'm excited.
I'm going to capture ghosts.
Oh, wait, wait.
No, Natcha should be last.
I want to ask Natcha on a question after.
Ditto, you go next.
Okay.
Hello, I'm Dino from Liji.
Yay.
Nice to meet you.
Yeah!
Okay.
Nachal.
Uh-oh.
She brought out the paper.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Nachal.
I want to speak English fluently, but I will try my best and
let's have fun today!
Yay!
Yeah!
Natchan!
Can you, what English words do you know, Natchan?
Can you...
Can you show us all your English?
Native English!
Yeah, native English!
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh, you, what the?
What?
Nice.
Natchan, did the hero teach you this?
Teach you right?
Right?
Where's Natcha?
Who teach you?
YouTube.
Natcha, Natcha, what did I teach you?
Natcha Yeah, yeah.
I taught you a word.
What did I teach you?
what the hell what does that mean that Chan amazing yeah I
taught her good English what do you mean I see I see I see
this is international collab we have Chinese English
Japanese
okay you're gonna be good teachers good teachers okay how do
we play I never played before I don't I never played you
guys are professional you guys never No, they played a
little bit.
Notchon and I, a little bit.
Little bit.
You played together.
Yeah, teach us, teach us.
Yeah, yeah.
Teach us.
Anything for the views.
Yeah, anything.
We're going to go viral.
Go viral.
Okay.
Go down to old world, film something scary.
All right, who's gonna die first?
Someone has to die for views.
What, me?
Why me?
Yes, Lou.
It should be you.
You were late!
You should die first!
Wait, who's gonna get the camera?
Light, light, light!
Camera.
Alright.
Wait, there's battery.
How do you charge battery?
Here, just, um, you can charge, charge battery here.
Oh, here?
Okay, how do I do that?
Stand here?
Yeah.
Oh, oh, I charged it!
I charged!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's be let's be streamers.
I'm ready.
we're gonna be famous guys okay there's something here wait
there's something here wait oh yeah oh hey oh okay oh right
you can't you can't change oh wait what's the e-mo I know
there's like emotes too let's emo uh t okay oh I don't have
emote I don't have money yes hello everybody Wait, film me,
film me, film me.
What?
Okay, okay, okay.
Film me, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
You guys, here, here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I will, okay.
Okay, I will give you a sign, okay.
Okay.
One, one, two, three, go.
Hello, everybody!
Today, Dino!
Today, Dino is going to die!
Okay, I'm done.
Okay.
I didn't show Okay, let's go Okay, let's go, let's go I
stopped Wake up Wake up, I was crazy I died Yeah All right,
how do we go?
Do we...
Oh, I need both of you Oh, submerged Is this it?
Submerged?
Oh I don't Door?
Okay Okay All right, here we go Okay, let's go It's cool Oh
my god, what the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
Alright, you can see your stamina on the...
Oh, I see.
Yay, I see.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
Alright, so we need to just...
make content right yeah yeah yeah okay okay someone dies you
get lots of views right when someone dies yeah we're gonna
go into this house let's
go oh i'm dead no we're not done we're alive
That's a volume!
Okay, don't worry, we're okay.
That's so scary.
It's not scary.
Yeah, it's not scary.
It's look at this, it's just a house.
Okay.
It's like a factory.
Yeah.
It's a factory We have to remember the way to go back Okay,
everyone Okay, okay, okay Don't worry, I won't get lost
Follow me, follow me, follow me I know how to make content
Follow you, follow you Yeah, follow me, follow me Follow me,
I'm content master Follow me, follow me Hello, monster
Monster?
Okay, don't, no, no, this way, this way, this way No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh!
Hey, hey!
Are you okay?
Wait, wait!
She's not- Wait!
Wait!
Look like this!
Look at him!
Okay.
Wait, you killed her!
Wait, this was a game!
I don't play!
Hello.
Hey, guys.
Oh, hey, hey, hey.
Hey guys, welcome to my channel.
He and- This is my best friend.
Ah!
That's my best friend!
Okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, wait.
Where are you?
Hiro!
Okay, I'm recording.
I'm recording.
Ah!
No, no, no!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to my channel.
This is my best friend, Gary.
Uh-huh.
And like today he and I were, he's gonna give us a tour of
the factory.
Okay, we follow, okay.
Oh my god.
Look, he's...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Yeah, I'm okay.
No, no, we gotta make more content!
We go deep, follow me, follow me!
Oh, downstairs.
No, no, no.
He just loves hugging.
That's the exit.
Yeah, we can, we can.
Oh, the exit?
Oh!
Wait, is he?
Is he nice?
What the hell?
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, I need to turn down my game volume.
Give me...
Okay.
Okay, I turned it down.
Wait, is he nice?
Like, wait, where did he go?
I was 0% better.
He's right there.
Oh, wait, wait.
Can you film him?
Film him.
Hello, guys.
Welcome.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
You can't see him?
You don't see him?
Yeah, I don't see him.
I don't see him.
He's right in front of you.
I don't see I don't see
Yeah, give me the camera give me the camera I can see him
No, it's a person Oh, is it full?
Oh, no, our content What is that?
I don't see It's just, it's a little boy It's a little boy
And he's like He's gone He doesn't like you He doesn't like
Alright, our first Our first Our first video, guys.
Our first video.
I can't hear the sound.
You couldn't hear it.
It was so loud.
Yeah, it was like...
I can't hear.
I can't hear like...
How did you die?
Okay, let's see.
Let's see what the video is like.
All right.
I got the CD.
Wait, I got it.
Hey, come here, come here, come here, everyone.
Come here.
Okay.
All right.
Two, two, three, go.
Hello everybody!
Hello!
Today's dinner is going to die!
Okay, I'm done.
Lots of views, right?
When someone dies?
Yeah!
We're gonna go into this house!
I'm gonna follow you!
Okay.
Don't worry, we're okay.
Yeah, follow me, follow me!
Follow me!
I'm confident.
Follow you!
Follow me!
What's that?
What's this?
Wait, she's dead!
What the heck is this?
You're cute!
Ah!
Hey guys.
Oh hey hey guys, welcome to my channel.
He and me, this is my best friend?
It's my best friend!
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to my channel.
This is my best friend, Gary.
And like today he and I were, he's gonna give us a tour of
the factory.
All right, hey, we follow.
Oh.
Oh, no.
We made $135!
Yay!
Yay,
money!
What was the comments?
Please do more of this kind of video.
Honestly, oh, honestly, I really like Hiro Chan's voice.
Now Chan looks dead.
Oh my god, you have fans, Hiro!
You know you're gonna be famous Oh my god Famous But I
achieved my dream of 1000 views Oh my god guys subscribe So
we can get 1000 subscribers For Hiro
Yeah time to sleep Time to sleep Yeah time to sleep How do I
sleep?
Sleep here, sleep here Wait, did I sleep yet?
Not yet, not yet.
Okay, wait.
This is my bed.
This is your bed?
It's my bed.
What?
Go sleep!
Okay, I'll sleep again then.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I sleep, I sleep.
I sleep.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm sleeping.
Sleep, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I sleep.
Sleep time.
I was just trying to give exclusive content.
Good morning.
Good morning, Ohio.
Good morning!
Today is another hard day of work.
Can we buy stuff now?
Yeah, we can buy.
What can we buy?
I got the camera.
Wait, who wants?
Wait, how do I use the camera?
Oh, selfie mode.
Oh, okay, okay.
You can aim on my liking and liking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or what do we buy?
Are you spending money on emotes?
Are you guys- No, no, no!
Are you emotes?
We want- we want to waste our money.
Yeah, yeah, we're not gonna waste our money, guys.
Okay, here, um, let's- Wait, wait, this one.
The hugger, hugger, hugger.
Somebody bought!
Who bought it?
Aida bought this!
I did.
You're right!
You're right.
Okay,
wait.
Can someone film, film me, film me, film me.
Film me, guys.
Nice car.
That is $100 of clapping.
Thank you.
Okay, don't worry, we can make it back.
That will get us like 500 viewers.
This will be 500 viewers, guys.
Don't worry.
Do you remember the monster that we met yesterday?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's not that scary.
Okay.
He's really weak.
He's... Oh, what the...
What the fuck?
He's really weak?
Okay.
Wasn't there another...
Let's find the little boy.
Damage.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
Alright, don't worry guys.
Follow me.
I can clap.
Okay, we find a little boy.
Don't worry, there's no fall damage.
Look at that, we're fine.
We're okay.
No fall damage We'll be fine Oh what's this Wait what is
that What is that Oh it's a head You give me head okay
Don't worry Oh Wait, that's scary!
Film something scary!
That's scary!
Wait, what's that?
What is that over there?
Whoa!
Whoa, what is that?
Wow!
Don't touch, don't touch, okay?
Okay.
But there's something there.
Instantly?
Something there.
Which one?
There's something there.
Can you see it?
Oh, yeah.
Where did...
Come in.
Oh!
Wait, where's...
I laughed at!
I laughed!
Die!
Wait, I clapped it!
I cried!
He's dead!
Be into the laser!
I can't believe it, I clapped to death.
Guys, I hope you guys are okay.
I hope you guys are okay.
I hope you guys are dying from the fall.
Sound guy, are you okay?
Sound guy!
I
Can't believe no one recorded it.
I can't he's crying
Okay, let me turn it down.
I can turn it down There you go Wait she left I can't
believe it.
I can't believe I could have to die That was so Alright,
ambient, okay, there should be a way to turn down the
fucking echo.
How the fuck do you turn down the echo?
Oh my god, what's over there?
What's over there?
Oh, that's the guy that slapped me!
That's the guy that fucking slapped me!
Oh my god!
He's got a knife!
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe I'll turn...
okay i'm gonna turn down here is it sound effects is anyone
recording
wait did everyone dead oh no oh that's how wait nacha's dead
oh the echo did not change poor sound guy, poor sound guy.
There's no way to fix the echo.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
That's Niz.
Dude, who's just like, Where do I go?
Oh my god, they're alive!
Wait, do you
still have film?
Where is Na-Chat?
What about where is Doki?
We lost two?
Okay.
What happened to where is Doki?
Doki?
Echo!
Yeah, my voice.
Why were they like, where is Na-Chat?
What about me?
What the fuck?
Why were you guys like, oh, why were you guys like, where is
Natchez?
What happened to where is Doki?
You guys didn't care about Doki.
Doki!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no one ever asked where Doki is.
Okay,
I'm ready.
This is $100 for a game.
Yeah.
I wonder if Don Quixote is having fun.
What is that?
I get you head.
Oh, it's a head.
You can be head, okay.
Oh!
But there's something there!
Oh my god!
Which one?
There's something there!
You see it?
Yeah.
For the...
Wait,
what?
There's no keystone?
No!
She's there!
Okay, angle, film this.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Don't keep her dying?
Are you leaving?
It just ends when you're crying.
Oh my god.
He just...
We did it!
We made $200!
Can't keep her dying?
Wait!
We've done so much!
Yeah, yeah, we can buy more stuff now!
Let's go!
Yeah, yeah, shop time, shopping, shopping.
It's shopping time.
Go bed.
It's shopping time!
Oh, wait.
Wait, is this shopping?
Okay, sorry, it's sleeping time.
No, we can't.
We can't shopping.
We can't shop.
But what a shop.
We have two friends to bed for it.
Okay.
Go to bed first.
This is my bed.
But I want to sleep here.
I want to sleep here, I'm blue!
I'm blue!
You're late!
Hey,
I sleep.
Sleep time.
See you tomorrow.
Money time tomorrow.
Time for more money.
Okay, don't worry.
We will...
Okay.
Ditto.
You buy for us.
Here, this one.
Hug.
Hug?
Can we hug like... Oh, what does hugger do?
Um, it can't hear you hear you hear your friend Oh Oh my
god, we should get Oh my god, we should get a mic Yeah, this
one here, hug Oh hug Let's hug I bought something
Watch this watch this Yeah, okay, I want a hug Wait, you're
my kids in the car.
My hunky.
That's okay.
I have perfect weapon.
You have flashlight.
You have flashlight here.
I can do this.
I can push people away.
Yeah, I got flashlight.
Are you ready?
Who is gonna free me?
Yeah, Natcha, Natcha, you film.
Natcha, Natcha, you film.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I'm ready.
Yes.
Ready too.
Don't worry, we make lots of money.
Natcha, I believe in you, Natcha!
Hey!
You can see the battery, you can see Kamala's battery.
If it's run out of battery, we can't see anything, okay?
Okay.
I'm pushing I'm pushing him.
I'm pushing him away
Did you did you hug?
Did you hug him?
Leave me alone
We leave, we leave!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, don't worry.
We'll be fine.
We're fine.
We gave him a hug.
It's okay.
We gave him a hug now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was not a tight hug.
Yeah, yeah.
Can someone heal me?
Wait, how do you heal?
You?
How do we heal?
Oh.
Okay, I'm gonna- Yeah.
How does this feel?
Is this?
Do you need hug, Nachan?
Do you need hug?
Here's a hug.
Hello, Nachan.
Oh my goodness!
Wait, what are you doing?
What's that???
What is that?
Someone hug me!
Someone hugmed me!
Okay, I don't have it.
It's here, it's here, it's here!
Hug me, hug me!
Hello.
All right.
Yeah, yeah, we're okay.
We have hugs now.
We have hugs.
All right.
Can we film the gun?
Oh yeah.
Get it.
Wait, what this?
What's this?
Oh, look.
Look.
Film this.
Yeah, film.
Wow.
Okay, that's good.
So beautiful.
Wow.
It's over.
Oh, there's another laser.
there's three don't worry I protect you guys don't worry oh
no no no I can't protect you guys oh there's more okay I'm
leaving goodbye oh guys okay
okay okay turn around guys guys what a guys oh okay okay
guys oh no oh no please somebody help me fuck is that oh
that's just okay guys you guys think they'll find me if i
just maybe if i just hide in this corner that everything
will be okay everything
it's okay i have but i have my guys it's okay they'll come
back for me right they're they're Gonna come back for me,
right, guys?
Hello?
Surely they'll come back for me.
Surely I'm important enough for them to rescue me, right?
No, no, no.
This is a night left for deads in there.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so fucked.
Guys!
I'm so fucked, I'm so fucked, I'm gonna do a merry-go-round.
Oh my god, they don't know.
They don't know they're aggroed to somebody else.
They know, they know, they know.
This is a hell, Mary.
There's no way I died to this laser.
There's no way.
You know what?
Down is up.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Down is up!
Down is always up!
No way!
Down is up!
Are we gonna make it?
We're gonna make it!
How do I...
How do I close this?
How do I close the door?
Oh no.
So how do I...
How do I close the door?
Why is it...
Why is it the door closed?
I broke it!
Oh no!
Oh!
where are my comrades the others are they still alive it'll
be funny if i just leave it'll be funny
diddo it'll be no chen oh it will be pretty funny but what
if i die i need to camera you'll lose if i do oh no but
where are they still alive distance 164 100 what they're
still like oh they're so fucking dead we do not have the
oxygen for this guys we we do not have the oxygen oh they're
out of oxygen wait how do how do i have more oxygen oh is it
Because I went up?
Oh, yeah, they're fucking dead, dead.
They're not even moving.
Saw me.
He saw me.
No!
I didn't do it!
It went closed!
It went...
I tried to close it.
Wait on the door.
Close the door.
I tried to close and went close.
It was just a bad dream, guys.
Just a really bad dream.
It's okay, it's okay.
We still have our channel.
We're gonna be big YouTube stars.
We're gonna be big streamers.
We're gonna be big Twitch streamers.
big YouTube, big Billy Billy streamers.
We're gonna be famous.
Really?
Yeah, really.
We are, we are Spoketoba, okay?
Here, go look.
We're gonna be big.
Spoketoba.
We're gonna be big Spoketoba.
We're going viral.
World tour.
Spoketoba.
World tour international.
We are content gods.
It's okay, we can do it again.
Let's go.
Yeah, we can go, okay.
hug okay no we have no hug it's okay guys do you know what
we do have
okay okay are you filming filming they may have taken our
hug but i'll still clap i'll still clap the most of emotes
whoa emotes forever emotes forever Okay, let me let me
explain the game.
Okay.
Yeah Okay, this game the camera is is very important.
Yeah, I'm alive.
We have to save the more than our life Okay, that's not my
fault.
You guys died.
I lived
I run away?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, you left me!
You left me!
I did not run away!
You guys left me to die!
No!
Left 4 dead!
And now it's our investigator!
Oh, yay!
Let's get everybody's back!
Hey, Gary.
Yeah, he shouldn't be our sign.
Why he's our...
Because he wants...
Because he wants to welcome us.
He's our best friend.
Again Oh my god So nice Our best friends Alright Yeah if we
are If we launch a monster I'm going to run away again
That's not true You all ran away from me You guys Ran away
from me Hiro Hiro Natsang And me We have here Yeah and all
three of you Ran away from me You ran away from me No, no,
no, no, I don't run away.
I don't run away.
I'm not a cat.
What is that?
Film it film it film it film it Oh my god
Okay, come here come here.
Follow me follow me see I didn't run away.
I didn't run away guys Yeah, follow me, follow me.
Okay, follow me.
Okay, nothing.
Okay, okay.
Back here, back here.
Don't follow me, follow me, follow me.
Oh, it's scary.
Oh, it's him again.
He's back.
Look, there he is.
Wait, that's his brain.
Where's it?
Hiro's dead.
Hiro.
Hiro die.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, she dead.
She's dead.
die oh oh she not chan not chan oh look at what not chan got
not chan okay okay yeah
follow me follow me oh i got one too there there oh look
look look
so cool
down is up down is up oh we're back here we're back in the
beginning Okay, we were here, right?
Yeah, we were here It says, um, the other exit Oh
Okay, I'm going up Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, he missed, he
missed, he missed, he missed Yeah, yeah, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, no, no, no, no, she's dead, she's dead,
she's dead, she's dead, No, she's dead.
She's dead.
No, no, no.
She's she's dead.
She's dead.
She's so dead.
Well, Natchan, you're alive.
Natchan!
I knew you were... You didn't die, Natchan!
Natchan, congratulations.
I'm so happy you're alive.
She keep telling me a fake news.
What do you mean?
It was real.
She's still alive.
She came back.
It's because it's like Jesus.
Yeah.
Yeah, Natchan's like Jesus.
Natchan, are you God?
No die.
Yes, see?
Okay, no die.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Right here.
No, she's dead.
I watched her die.
I watched her.
Yay!
Goodbye, Hiro.
Goodbye.
Let's welcome back.
Hiro.
Welcome back.
I have a ghost.
Hiro, I saw that i saw you run into the laser
how is our stream we're gonna be famous guys yeah i'm ready
okay okay okay
because he wants because he and he wants to welcome us Hiro,
Naha-chan and me, we are here every time.
We're going to
die!
We're going to die!
No,
no, no!
No, no!
I am going to die!
Okay, Hiro's dead.
Hiro's dead.
Oh my god, he's going to die.
Natchan
It's okay, it's okay If Natchan dies, it's okay
It's okay It was okay It was okay Look Look We got We got
One One dot nine Look at us We're almost at $300 Yay,
good morning!
Ohio!
Bye, good morning, guys, okay.
Good morning, another day of making content.
Sopping, sopping, honey.
That's content down.
Yeah, we need a hugger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One hugger and one flashlight, all flashlight.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Wait, do you still have money?
Yeah, we do.
We have like...
We have $172.
Ooh.
It's like a sound board.
Oh, yeah.
The sound board.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good, good, good purchase.
What else should we get?
We should have...
How much do we have?
$70?
Can we afford anything?
Oh, my God.
Yeah?
What is this?
Here.
I think we're going to be in the race.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
I ordered something that I really want.
That's it.
I already used it.
Wait, we should buy another one.
We should buy another one.
Party party.
I didn't know it was one use.
No one told me it was one use.
There it is.
Okay, okay, okay.
When we...
We survive?
Okay, I know when to use this.
When we survive, I'll use this.
Look, I have a sound boy.
What's this?
It's a sound boy.
Oh, you're like the sound player.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I hope the sound player.
Wait, what's this?
It's evil.
How to...
What is that?
What is this?
What are you doing?
I don't know.
Are you like flying?
You're flying.
Alright, let's go.
Let's film content.
It's content time.
I have Hegel so I can heal you guys.
Alright.
Nice.
I love Heels.
Okay.
I have...
Hegel.
I'm gonna...
Big Bang Theory.
Okay, don't worry.
That scared me actually.
Cool transition.
Oh my god, I don't like the song.
Oh, this is gonna make everything sound good.
Y'all be careful!
The dance beads box.
Don't worry, when it's funny, I'll play this.
So everyone will know it's funny.
Everyone will play.
I just feel like that is...
It's face carry.
Woo!
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
I should have recorded that.
Oh, that's a lot of lasers.
Wait, wait, wait, I got it, I got an idea.
Okay.
Let's go.
You got this.
Oh,
did you record it?
You did?
Okay, nice, nice content.
Okay.
I can do this too.
Nice, look at us.
We're so good.
We're already so...
Yay!
Alright.
We need to find some monsters for content.
Oh, there's a head here.
I haven't seen any monsters yet.
Follow me, follow me.
I'm so good at finding monsters.
Oh, here, here, here.
Crouch down.
There we go.
Oh,
there's two, there's two, there's two!
Are you filming?
I'm playing music
Where's our cameraman?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, oh I got an idea I got an idea!
Okay, okay, film me, film me, film me, film me!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Film me, okay, right here, okay.
Wait, we need to get Gary out of the picture.
Get Gary out.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Film me here.
Did I...
Are you filming?
I got the camera.
Got it?
It was worth it.
You know what?
Yeah, you got that?
Okay.
Okay, we got, we got content.
Oh my god, he's following me.
Oh, okay, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, we're back in the beginning.
Wait, is there anything else here?
I think this is new area.
Yeah, what's your HP?
Do you need hug?
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, we can hug you.
Okay, okay.
you okay wait film us film us hugging are you filming us
hugging okay okay now
No, let's see, let's sleep.
Let's go, let's sleep, let's sleep.
Let's go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
The monster wanted a hug too.
He wanted a hug.
Maybe we can hug now, we can hug.
Yeah, we can hug.
Oh my gosh.
I got like 10 HP.
Your HP was good.
Uh, yeah?
Where?
Where am I?
This way, this way, this way.
Come, come, come, come, come.
That's how.
Okay, okay, okay.
Come, come, come.
This way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She knows where.
I found her.
We found her.
We're home, we're home!
We did it!
It was like why?
Oh!
It's okay, it's okay, it's same guy, same guy!
Yeah, it's okay, we can't.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, we can't run, we can't run Yeah, we
can't run.
Yeah!
See, we're faster!
Don't worry about it, Chet!
Come on, come away, come!
Go, go!
Go, go, go!
It's okay, there's no more, no more monster.
Alright, do you still have film?
Natchan, do you still have film, Natchan?
We did it.
Zero?
Okay.
I think we got it.
I like how Hiro's bill, hospital bill is one dollar.
Hello!
How did you die?
They...
They... they comboed me.
Oh, they smashed you in the wall!
Yeah.
Okay.
Does anyone else want to do sound?
And hug?
Alright, you guys ready?
See ya!
Alright, let's go, let's watch.
Okay.
Are you really flying?
You're flying!
I'm flying!
Hey, it's scary!
Careful!
I got an idea.
Let's go!
The sound is...
It's so cute!
Oh!
Did you hear so scary?
I like it!
That is how she died.
Oh my god.
Oh, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Okay, okay, fill me, fill me, fill me.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Got it?
He's following me.
Back
in the beginning.
Okay.
Hello.
it's okay you live you live yeah we can stack we can stack
the CD um yeah we can stack the CD oh nice oh really yeah we
can yeah we can nice that's good to know yeah like um
tomorrow we We don't play it and we will play it in another
day.
Oh!
We can stack the viewers.
Shopping time!
Shopping!
Guys, it's time to shop.
What
are you buying?
I'm gonna buy something really helpful.
It'll be really helpful, I swear.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, watch.
So we know when to film.
Watch this.
Lights, camera, action.
Are you guys right?
Okay, are you ready?
Are you ready to film?
Okay, okay, okay.
Na-chan, are you ready?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Two,
one!
Whoa, so good!
That's so good, Natchan!
Professional.
So professional.
Wait, wait.
We need this.
Natchan, Natchan.
Pick this up.
What is this one?
This one, this one.
Oh, Natchan, reporter.
Mike.
Okay.
Natcha, what do you want to say, Natcha?
Go.
Go, Natcha, say something.
Say something.
You're on camera!
What?
Wait, what's this?
What is that?
Yeah.
This is goo ball.
What's that do?
Um, it can, um, how can I say it?
I think it's like, um, it's a goo.
What does it do?
You can, you can try it.
You can try it.
We can't show it, um, at the monster.
Oh, is it one use?
Yeah, this one use, yeah.
Oh, it's one use.
It's okay.
Oh my god, it's so slow.
I guess it slows people down.
Yeah, it's so sticky.
Yeah, we can slow the monster by this one.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Let's buy more.
Yeah, we have $100 so we can buy.
I can't take it because on the slot is four yeah i i can i
can take one yeah one's four do you order oh no okay i'm
gonna order yeah yeah yeah all right all right are we gonna
Okay Wait, what what what what did you say what did you what
what did you what did you know what okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, Doki is gonna die first Okay,
who wants to be Mike
Oh, he knows the interviewer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'll interview.
Okay, interview the monsters.
Interview the monsters when we see them.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here we go.
Hey, guys.
Welcome back to another video.
Welcome back.
I don't know.
Like and subscribe.
Haha.
The laughing is so scary.
We need to have five monsters to interview.
We have five monsters to interview.
Oh, God.
That's so scary.
That's so spooky.
What's over there?
There's lasers here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can't get past that.
That one we can't.
I can't get past.
So maybe here.
Oh, there's a rib cage.
Boom.
Here we go.
Are you filming?
How do you feel today, sir?
Oh, my God.
Is this a maze?
Oh, there's another one.
Wait, what's over here?
Yeah, this place is like a maze.
Yeah, that's like a maze.
Where are all the monsters?
I found zero monsters.
We need a fucking interview one.
Monsters!
That's the exit.
There's no monster.
Yeah.
Monster!
We need you for content monster!
All the monsters are scared of us.
Why are they so scared?
Monster.
You get my iron.
Let us use you for content.
We want to be famous YouTubers and streamers and Billy,
Billy streamers and Twitch streamers.
Oh my god.
There's actually zero monsters.
I have some place in the gym.
Please.
We have found zero.
Oh my god.
We have the coming out of the valley.
34% of the...
34?
Oh no, we need to find the monsters.
Okay.
Alright, we got a speed run.
There has to be one person.
Let us use you for views.
Oh, I found the entrance.
How is there nobody?
I don't have no one.
There's a lake.
Yeah, laser here.
Yeah.
What?
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
Hello?
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck is this?
Yeah, what the fuck is that?
What?
I didn't even see it.
I think we needed a...
I didn't see it either.
Yeah, I didn't see anything either.
It just exploded in front of me.
How do we get out of here?
Oh my god, I'm lost, guys.
Wait, this is new.
We're so lost.
Maybe someone died for the content.
Hiro.
Yeah, where's Hiro?
Where's Hiro?
Hiro?
Where's our interview?
Oh, there you are!
What is that?
What is it?
That's a radio!
This is my first time.
First time.
Yeah, it's a radio.
Oh!
I like it.
I feel like...
Jara's This is content Just film the dance its content Its
content People love it It's like tiktok It's like tiktok
Yeah we're doing tiktok dance Everyone dance Tiktok Oh Film
her!
Film her!
Oh she's gone Goodbye I think I think
Yeah, yeah, yeah, oh yeah, we have to go back we have to go
back We have to go back Natchan, Natchan, she's dead Natchan
Come back Natchan Leave her, leave her, leave her, leave her
Leave her, leave her You have the camera, right?
Natchan, come, come We leave She's dead, it's okay She's
dead, we have to leave Be careful.
We leave her for content.
It's okay.
She gave us good content.
From zero monsters to like...
Oh my god, I hate...
I hate you.
I don't like your love.
Oh, entrance, exit, exit, exit.
We're doing it.
Okay, guys, go back.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's okay We didn't lose anything Yeah, what is that?
So from zero monsters to all monsters That was so fucking
crazy That was crazy Hey, now chat
Okay, now we leave.
Well, it looks like...
No, I think...
No, Hiro's definitely dead.
No, she's... she's gone.
Okay, Alice.
She's gone.
It was for content, okay?
It's just a prank.
Oh, she was like $0.
dollars.
Hiro was zero dollars.
That's good.
Welcome back, Hiro.
It dragged me.
It dragged me to the lasers, by the way.
Oh, you died to the lasers?
The slime took me to the laser.
It took me there and I died.
What the hell?
Look, see, I didn't die first.
I didn't die first, guys.
Alright.
Oh, we didn't stack.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We don't need a Okay.
Oh, so smart.
Yeah, because we, yeah, Tenza.
We already got our money.
It's okay.
We'll have money next time.
Okay, good morning.
Good morning, everybody.
Good morning.
Are you guys ready to make more content?
Time for more content All right, we don't we can't we can't
afford anything though.
We're poor now.
Yeah, yeah, we have one dollar We can't afford anything for
one dollar.
I need to charge my my I need to charge my flashlight
Yo, where are you eating Ditto?
Where are you eating?
All right, let's go Let's go.
It's time to make more content content.
Content time.
We gotta make money.
We need all the money.
Yeah, Hino, don't die.
You're always dying, Hino.
Hino, you're always dying.
What do you mean?
Who's falling?
Wait, whoa.
What's this map?
Don't die.
This is a new map.
Is this new map T is really hard.
Oh really how is it hard?
There's monsters, there's monsters, there's monsters,
there's monsters.
Okay,
you left you left you scared you left Who has hug?
Wait, wait, we have hug.
I have hug.
Hug, hug, hug, hug.
Yay.
I'm full hug, he's back.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's back.
Hido, you need hug.
Hug Hido.
You gotta hug Hido.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
He ran away.
He got scared!
The three of his shirt back?
Oh my god.
Alright, alright.
It's okay, he got scared.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can't hug.
I don't...
I don't like personal touch.
I don't like...
Okay, I'm fine now.
Okay.
Thank you.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Natcha, do you need hug?
Oh, wait, Natcha discovered something!
No!
I'm gonna do it.
Guys.
Film me.
Woo!
I'm okay.
There's nothing wrong here.
It's just a hole.
Guys.
Did you film it at least?
Guys, jump down!
Oh no.
I don't think they jumped down, chat.
I don't think they jumped down.
It's okay.
I've done this before.
Down is up.
It's okay.
I've done this before.
Down is up.
Surely.
Okay, maybe not that down.
Maybe.
Maybe not that down.
guys hello guys why didn't nobody jump down with me oh no i
can't believe it i did all of that for content and nobody
filmed anything these are unprofessional content creators am
i the only one that takes my job seriously i don't like
this.
Oh, I really don't like this.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Oh, no.
I hope they don't leave me for dead.
Surely they won't, right?
Surely I'm more important to them, right?
Oh, no.
Oh, I don't like this.
I'm so fucking dead, guys.
Wait, I hear you guys!
Huh?
Where are you guys?
Oh!
I did it!
Wait, where is it?
We were dying to the knife.
Wait, you're dying to that?
I'm the only one.
I have like 100 HP.
Look at that.
I did all of that!
And you guys didn't film anything!
You guys didn't film anything.
I can't believe it!
We have to hide now.
What is that?
Oh my god, oh he hurts, he hurts, he hurts.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go,
let's go, let's go, come back, come back, come back.
Wait, who has the camera?
Natchan, Natchan, leave her!
Natchan, leave her!
She's dead!
Natchan, she's dead!
Natchan's dead!
chance too?
Yeah, flash flashlight.
Okay, let's go.
Let's leave.
Wait, did you have that kid?
Did you film them already?
Yeah.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Wait, wait, wait.
That one, the one that has big dice, yeah?
We can, we can just the flashlight to him, okay?
He oh, okay.
Yeah, if we just the flashlight to him.
Oh, I see.
Okay, I need hugs.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
hug you need to get a hug oh you saw film okay okay okay we
hug each other we end it with a hug okay okay okay okay you
said film right it's okay we don't have to pay money for her
death that's the best part all right all right wait wait who
has a hug who has a hug
Someone hug and then we film it Okay, yeah, okay, I'll do
the sound effects someone okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, give me a sign.
Okay, ready three?
Okay, three two one
That was good.
That was great.
That was a great that was a great hug Emo?
Emo?
Yay!
Wow!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, you have more?
I don't know.
3%, 3%, 3%, okay, come here, come here, come here, come
here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here,
come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, Come
here, come here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I saw this on the internet.
Okay, diddo get on the bed?
Okay.
Okay, are you ready, film?
Are you ready?
You can lie down in bed?
Yeah, are you ready?
Are you ready?
Yeah.
What are you gonna do?
Okay, okay.
We didn't do anything.
What did it?
Why are you going?
Why are you doing?
What are you doing?
I did nothing.
What?
I didn't do anything.
Nothing.
It was too
spicy.
Oh no!
No!
The content was too spicy!
Really?
We got demonetized Okay, okay, okay, okay Nice, nice, nice,
nice Wait, wait, wait, wait, we watched the yesterday The
yesterday Okay, okay, okay, okay Let's watch yesterday Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah Okay, three, two, one What DOOM Oh, I
wonder if that he's a girlfriend
huh interview the monsters interview the monsters when we
see them okay okay okay all right how do you feel
are you feeling how do you feel today how do you feel today
sir
I have to have zero monsters We didn't fucking interview one
Oh, this is when the thing exploded on us That's the radio
Yeah, it's the first time I saw it Yeah, it's a radio It's
like TikTok We're doing j-cut
That was a good cut that was a good cut We can save we can
save we can save the card here.
Okay, I saved the video.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Okay, next video I'm gonna save the video I
like hand
What the fuck is going on?
You shot film, right?
a bit
more emo emo time
I was hugging I was hugging what you I was hugging what do
you If you want to see the rest of it, you gotta get the...
Directors cut.
You know, the directors cut.
Oh, guys, look, look, look!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, yeah, oh shit, can we pause this?
Oh my god.
Can we do it?
We made so much money!
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's sleep time!
Sleep time!
Okay, I saved the video.
Whoa!
Good morning!
Good morning, everybody!
I had a great time!
Hey, wait!
We can, we can, um, we can here, we can buy this one.
I will.
The revive one here.
Oh, revive!
That's good!
Yeah, defibrillator.
Yeah, we can buy it one.
Did you buy one yet?
Did you buy it?
Yeah, not yet, not yet.
Okay, I'll buy.
We can rewrite T-Tam in one game.
Okay, and then...
I'm gonna buy...
The thing is, don't die.
No, the shark stick.
Okay.
Yeah, don't die, guys.
Don't die.
Oh, yeah, I want to try filming.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm going to throw this.
And then...
I'm going to throw this.
No!
We don't have enough money for this!
Alright, my turn to film.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I know how to make a good movie.
Alright, I bought us a defibrillator.
Which one?
This one?
Yeah.
Yeah, I know.
Alright, are you guys ready to film?
Okay!
Alright.
We can do this.
We're gonna be famous!
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
You have to charge the battery, charge the battery.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, let me charge my flashlight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me charge...
I'm gonna charge my battery, my flashlight.
So, Director Doki is here.
Alright.
Welcome to my documentary.
What did you order?
Wait, what did you buy?
Did you buy that?
Who?
Yeah.
Are you guys ready?
Go, go, go.
All right.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Let's go.
This is gonna, we're gonna make so much money, guys.
Oh my god, I'm a lady.
Oh my god, my first night.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
My first night.
What happens if we, like...
Leave?
Oh.
Kill me?
We're not allowed to break it.
We are not.
Unlucky.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I believe in us to make lots of money for this one because
I'm filming.
Alright, let's go.
Alright.
Let's go!
Ready!
Oh, it's from back here!
Go!
Let's go!
Okay, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, come here, come
here!
Wait, where's the hole?
How do we open this hole?
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
I will teach you!
Wait, guys!
Okay?
If you even get caught, you have to throw the item to this
one.
Here, throw the item.
Oh, okay.
Okay!
Alright, here you go.
I'm gonna get caught.
Oh!
Yeah!
Throw the item!
Is she dead?
Is she...
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god, oh my god, why is she going?
Wait, how do you open this hole?
How do we open this?
We can't, we can't.
Oh, we can.
There's no... Oh, it's random.
Wait, is there a hole here?
No, there's no holes.
Alright, let's go down.
You like holes?
Yeah, yeah, I like all the holes.
We go down.
No, let's go all the way down, guys.
All the way down.
That's where the real content is.
Go down.
This is it.
Woo!
I don't know how much battery I have left.
Help me.
right i think top right oh i see it okay yeah top right
let's find some monsters what's that what is this wait do
you look at the void it's the void what is this who touched
me wait wait she has the camera she has the camera oh my god
oh my god
Oh my god!
Why would they push the camera?
Push, push, push!
What is that?
Oh my god, it was an accident Kaido, let's go home They
don't have the camera But we have to find a way out
Actually, I don't know I can't believe it, I worked so hard
I'm making such good content I can't believe it Oh, my
content Recto debut!
Hello!
And they would do this to me.
Oh, this way?
Yes!
This is what they get.
I'm glad I told them to all go downstairs.
Can't believe it.
My first...
Recto debut.
I hope Ditto dies.
Oh no!
Come here!
Wait, what the fuck was that?
What the fuck was...
What is that?
What was that?
Oh,
this way!
I remember this!
This means that I have to go through.
If I was still alive, I would have taken them home.
This was the exact same way I did to find my way home.
Okay, okay.
Let's go, let's go.
How can they go home without the camera?
I can't believe they would survive.
I can't believe it.
They did not deserve it.
They did not deserve to live.
They should have died with me!
If they were true homies, they would die with me.
Oh my gosh.
What the fuck?
Why is that so falling?
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
it my hospital bill is 26 i who pushed me who pushed me
ditto
you know it's you it's you it was you who else would it be
I'm going to just leave.
Now I'm mad.
Rage video.
Okay, wait.
It's me.
Nice, nice, nice.
Now I'm mad.
Now I hope we never become famous.
I hope we never become famous.
I have camera again.
Do we...
Film again, film again, you dropped the last time.
I'm mad now.
Do we have...
Okay, wait.
What do we have?
How much money we have left?
Okay, we have...
234.
What, 234?
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, we should!
Something, something!
Oh yeah, shopping time, shopping time!
Don't worry.
Oh god, that's content.
Really?
Yeah.
Watch this.
Content.
Can I- can I film myself while doing this?
Can I do that?
I don't know.
Okay, I didn't want to buy a flashlight.
We have no money.
No, we can buy a flashlight.
We can?
It's only $20 one.
Oh, $20?
Okay.
I lost it.
All right, let's go.
You guys ready for content?
Okay, ready.
Content time.
Let's go.
Nachan, you should be leader.
Nachan.
Leader.
How do you go?
Yeah, you're a leader.
Yeah, you go.
You go.
We follow.
We follow you, Nachan.
Follow me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's this again.
Oh, it's here again.
Where do we go, Nachan?
Okay.
Where do we go?
We're following?
Whoa, look at all this.
What is this?
It's just glasses.
Where are the monsters, though?
Monsters.
Natcha, Natcha, Natcha, Natcha.
Okay, okay.
This time, someone should die for content, though.
We would get more money.
When we get more money if somebody dies on camera I think so
Yeah That's right as leader you should do it You die Go yeah
Go die Yes die Yes You guys That's how you should do it
It'll be so funny It'll be so funny How can you tell Go die
soon Yeah
Yeah, what is it?
Oh, oh, we can go.
We can go
nice.
I'm ready.
Yeah.
Okay, go go.
Oh, what's that?
Natchan touch it Go touch it.
Oh
You touch it What was that?
Whoa, what is that?
I feel like that's a monster.
Do you see that?
That chat are you there?
Oh, that chat is Whoa
Okay Someone help me Okay Okay Okay, someone hug me!
Wait, wait, where's hug, hug, hug, hug?
Hug, yeah, yeah, hug me, yeah.
Nice, okay, I'm okay now.
Hey, Hiro, Hiro.
Where's Hiro?
Hiro?
Is Hiro dead?
I think Hiro died.
Yeah.
I think she's dead.
It all?
Yeah, she's dead.
Wait, wait, does she have the defibrillator?
Wait, who has it?
Who has the defib?
Oh, here she has it.
She has it.
We have to go back to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Revive.
Yeah, we can revive her.
Oh, there she is.
There's her dead boy.
Wait, wait, wait.
Before you revive her.
Let's let me...
What's that?
Okay, someone revive her.
I'll film.
Okay.
See him?
Revive!
Let's go!
She's reviving!
Oh shit!
Fuck, okay!
Oh my god!
I'm dead.
I'm okay!
I'm okay.
I'm going up.
It's okay.
okay don't you not okay in that chat okay okay we're good
we're good we're good we can't we can't leave my part we
can't leave my part oh let me hear you okay okay okay yes
hug okay okay okay okay okay here you go how about you i'm
good i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm good hey i can hug i can
hug don't worry okay okay am i hugging okay okay okay okay
but we'll watch this one more one
Okay, all right, we're good.
All right, I'll wait here.
Okay.
Because we have to go anyway.
Are we going to let...
Are we going to revive Hiro?
No, we can't because it's still battling.
Okay, all right, let's go.
Let's leave.
Let's go.
Where do we go?
Wait, Natchan.
Leader.
No, no, no, no.
Natchan, leader.
Why not?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no We have to go back Okay Okay,
okay, okay, go home Go home Home time If we run out of the
ocean, we will die too Oh yeah, yeah, that's true, that's
true We have to Home time, I believe in you Oh, okay We can
do this Okay Wait, where?
We go up We go up and go left side is home.
We're gonna die.
Oh, nice.
We're not gonna die, JK.
Left side, left side.
I think left side.
Oh, wait, I know this.
Yeah, yeah, we go here, and then right, and then left, left,
left, left, left, yeah, yeah, I memorized this.
And then it is this way.
And then We go forward?
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm a genius.
I'm a genius, guys, by the way.
Subscribe to Doki Bird at YouTube.
I'm fucking...
I'm never lost.
We did it!
Okay, okay.
Guys, guys, guys, before we go, let's...
Let's film ourselves real fast.
Guys, guys, guys, look.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
Hero died.
What a loser.
Okay, no bad.
He...
Hi
Hiro are you back?
Hiro Hiro's back guys Hiro's back Where's Hiro?
Hiro?
Where is she?
Oh Hiro!
I found Hiro!
I found her!
Okay She was hide and seek right now.
Alright, don't worry, guys.
I filmed something amazing.
You guys love it.
How do I put this?
Do I just throw it?
Wait, wait.
Are we gonna play it today, or tomorrow?
Yeah, today.
No, no, no, no.
Today.
You got, today.
We need it.
Don't worry.
You guys will know why we play it today.
Okay,
you guys are gonna love it.
You guys are gonna love it.
I think it's, like, my best work.
You guys will love it.
Okay.
Can you?
I'm so fast!
That's great!
She is already coming!
I wish she died.
This is easy.
Where is he?
No!
Come here, come here, come here, come here!
You can't go up!
It's so perfect.
It's beautiful.
Look at the 18,000 people.
So many people watched us.
Yeah, so many people.
Wow
$300 I made us three hundred dollars Yeah Look at that We're
ready.
We're ready.
Look.
We made a quota Yeah, I'm gonna save it.
You're gonna save it?
Look at that.
I made us so much money I'm so good Oh,
yeah.
Good morning.
Oh, hi.
Oh, hi, yo.
We did it.
We're there.
Look at us.
We're making so much money.
All right, who wants to film next?
Um, Okay, Hiro.
Alright, Hiro.
Wait, how much money we got?
What's 320?
Should we save our money?
Okay, I need a flashlight.
Yeah, I need a flashlight, though.
I saved the channel.
What are you guys gonna get?
Oh, I don't have any moat yet.
Yeah, you should buy any moat.
Yeah, buy an emote for more content.
Backflip.
Backflip?
Oh, it's 300.
Yeah, we can afford it.
Oh, wait, we should get rid of the part.
Yeah.
Wait, why did you add two-party profit?
Oh, my God.
Alright, nice.
Let's try it.
Alright.
I'll try.
Oh, my God.
You should film yourself doing a backflip.
It's gonna look great.
Yeah, film yourself with a backflip.
What does it look like?
Oh!
What the...
Oh my god, that was beautiful.
That was...
10 out of 10.
It was so beautiful.
Yeah, yeah, no, no.
Yeah, you did.
You did.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You definitely did.
You definitely did, you know.
It was...
Did you flame it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She filmed it.
Yeah, I did.
Oh, okay.
That is nice.
Income.
It was so sick.
It was, like, the best backflip I've ever seen.
Wow, thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
Is this the same map or new map?
Oh, it's this map.
Yeah, it's the same map.
Guys, I can't die because I have hug.
You need me.
I need you.
You guys need me.
Wee!
Yay, I have hug.
I have hug.
I can hug anybody.
Hug for his.
Monster.
We want to make content.
Monster?
Would you want to be interviewed, Monster?
Oh, what's this?
Wait, what is that?
It's a toy bee.
A famous monster for our channel.
Look at this.
Let's look at this.
This is doggy.
Yeah, this is me.
You can buy it for $5.99.
Subscribe to Doki Bird.
I know, so cheap.
It's almost the same price as a membership.
That's how cheap it is.
Monster.
there's a monster we need to make money I heard we if we
stay longer there would be like bigger monsters yeah yeah
yeah we just have to like stay longer for bigger monsters to
show up
monster no we want to see big monsters big monsters equals
more views oh there There's more, there's more, there's more
spines.
Film it.
I can...
Look at all these spines.
Whoa!
This will make good soup.
Good soup.
I'm gonna put it in my soup base.
Wait, how do...
Wait, is this dead end?
Where's door?
Oh, the sword!
No, no, no, no, no!
Goodbye!
How he gets here?
Hug is here.
Oh, she's dead.
Hug.
Oh, she's dead again.
Revive, not chat, revive, not chat.
So, I can hug her.
Okay.
She's back.
She's back, she's back, he's back.
Okay, okay, okay.
We gotta leave.
Where's the exit?
Hug, hug, hug, hug, hug.
Don't worry.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, don't worry, come over here,
come over here for a while.
Huff me, huff me, huff me.
I like it.
Oh yeah, well I know, it's like, okay.
Huff me,
hold on.
Don't worry, I'm just kidding.
I can't, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Kiss this for the bros.
You don't kiss your bro.
If they're dying, you gotta kiss the bro.
Gotta kiss the homies.
Oh my gosh.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Wait, how did you guys get?
up there okay don't worry don't worry do you need a hug too
okay don't worry
oh my god there's there's so much jokie bird to go around
guys there's so All right, I need someone to hug me Gotta
kiss the homies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need someone to hug me.
I'm all hugged out
Wait, why is it dangerous?
Because they have a dog machine that got dog gun.
Oh, the dog gun.
Oh, okay, okay Where do we go?
Yeah, yeah.
Where'd you go?
Let's see.
Oh my god, oh my god, we gotta leave, we gotta leave.
Oh my god.
I hug you, I hug you.
Come on, come on, give me, give me, give me, I hug, I hug.
Go away.
Oh, he's gonna die.
Yeah?
Oh, he is gonna die.
Don't worry, I'm gonna hug.
I got hug.
I got the kisses Oh shit I don't want Okay okay okay Where
is she Where is she Hiro Hiro Hiro Oh my god I can't see her
I can't see her Wait I think she ran up No she ran This is
outside Yeah yeah This is outside Hiro Did Hiro die?
Oh okay Did she run away Without us?
Wow Hiro Wow Wow Hiro.
Hiro.
Wait, I think she is dead.
Wait, but she has the camera.
Yeah, she has the camera.
What do we do?
We have to go back, go back, go back.
Okay, not we have to go back.
One of us has to go back.
Okay, here's the hug.
Okay, wait, wait.
Are we all full HP?
All of us.
Yeah, I'm full HP.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's
go Look, it's not my fault It's not my fault, okay Like,
look, I was dying from lack of oxygen And Hiro is Hiro and
Nachan is definitely dead
I'm pretty sure Nachan is dead too Like, they're not moving.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
Ditto's still alive.
She's still moving.
So technically she's still alive.
She's coming over?
I think?
This is 98.
Oh, it stopped at 90.
Oh, no, no, no.
It's still moving.
She has 5% oxygen left, but she's still moving.
Look!
Look at the manual!
There's hearts around it.
I'm giving the homies a...
A kiss for good luck.
Okay.
Oh, she's coming back.
Oh, wouldn't it be funny if she died with 0% oxygen?
Let me see.
Oh, she's definitely dead.
Oh, she's dead.
Oh, she is.
Wait, 26 meters?
I might be able to get the camera.
She might have died here.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, she did not get the camera
Okay, she did not get the camera All right, goodbye
It's okay Guys, it's okay I got the defibrillator Guys, I
got this I got great.
It's okay guys.
I got this back Yeah, yeah, yeah, we'll get the camera
tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah.
I know where it is.
I didn't find
it right by the way Yeah, it's like where where did Hiro go?
You know where everybody missed me.
Don't go, Hiro
It's like don't go
It's okay, I lived.
Alright, alright, someone take the...
Alright, someone take the revive.
Revive and hug.
I'm all, I'm all like, hugged out.
Please revive me.
I'm all hugged out now.
I've hugged too many people.
Come on, we have no money.
No money.
We don't have flashlight.
I have flashlight.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait!
Do you charge?
Do you charge the battery?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, 17%.
Good thinking.
I'm recharging.
I had almost no battery.
Don't worry.
Here you go.
Wait, where are you charging?
Oh, the defib.
Revive.
Alright guys.
Are you guys all ready?
Don't worry.
We're gonna have...
cool don't worry no worries we're gonna make we're gonna
make content here oh wait this is new is this new I never
seen this oh yeah all right I got fast that wait who has
camera wait is that oh I give you I give you the house I'll
give you the help.
Wait, who's hugging?
Ooh.
Wait, I go get the other camera.
Oh, there's other camera.
I got it.
Oh, the other camera.
Wait, there's another one.
There's another one.
Put me under.
Look, look, look.
Film, film, film.
Okay, now.
Look at this.
It's so beautiful.
This is five.
This is one Akasupa.
If you want to have this, it is one Akasupa.
Okay, we'll go.
It's so cheap Wait,
wait, are we waiting for Hiro?
Wait, wait, wait for Hiro?
Wait for Hiro?
Okay.
I'm gonna explore you.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna find a monster and bring it to them for content,
guys.
It's gonna be... Just think about the views, chat.
Think about the...
How much... How viral we're gonna get monster.
Come on.
This man right here.
I'm right here.
Wait, where is it?
Where did he go?
Did he blow himself up?
Wait, did the monster...
Did the monster blow himself up?
Hello?
Wait, they left me.
I have the flashlight.
Where do they go?
Hello?
Did I?
Not, Chad!
They left me!
Why could they leave me like this?
Oh, no.
I have nothing.
What's that?
I can't believe it.
I would never ditch them.
That's so fucked up.
There it is.
I would never do such a thing.
Hello?
Guys?
Where the fuck are they?
Wait, this is a new area.
is our ship though oh no where is our ship oh ship is over
there oh my god it's so fucking far why is the ship so what
do you mean i'm innocent i never leave anybody i said i was
gonna bring i i was trying to help us get content i was
trying to help us find a monster just to get us content but
it's okay i know where they are okay Let me head back to the
ship and see if they're still alive.
Hello, guys.
Are you guys still alive?
Are they still moving?
They're still moving.
Okay.
Okay, they're still alive.
They're very...
Oh, my God.
They're getting further and further away from the ship.
I have no idea where they are.
Oh, my God.
They're so far away.
Guys, they're so fucking far away.
How the fuck am I supposed to...
Hello?
You do not hear jacked shit.
What do you mean you can still hear them?
Look at how far they are away from me.
How do you have 60% oxygen still?
Is this here?
No, that's Ditto.
Did you spend your time in the ship?
Okay.
Wait, do I lose oxygen if I...
Alright.
They're still really far away from me.
All right.
They seem to...
Yeah, they...
No, I'm pretty sure they're together.
I'm pretty sure.
They just don't have a flashlight at all.
They just...
They're definitely together.
It's just that they don't have a flashlight.
All right.
Okay.
And they have the camera.
They're making content.
Guys!
Hello?
Are you guys still alive?
Okay.
Guys?
Natchen!
Follow my voice!
Hello?
Where are you?
Are you here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm up here!
Oh my god!
Where did you guys go?
You're alive!
I'm here!
Yeah, yeah, and I said wait, I said wait, and then I was...
What?
Natchen?
I said, I said, wait, I said, yeah, yeah, yeah, wait here.
I found a monster!
I was gonna give you guys content!
Do you guys got content?
Okay, okay, let's go downstairs, let's go downstairs.
We still have time.
Yay!
I found, like, a monster when you guys were in here.
Look, there it is!
Oh, hello!
Oh, my God!
I got Lion King!
It's like Lion King!
Get picked up!
Get picked up for content!
Content!
Oh, good content!
Good content!
Oh, they're picking her up.
She's picking...
Natasha is fucking dead.
Oh my god!
Okay, okay.
I need one.
Holy shit.
Okay, okay.
Wait, who else died?
Leave it!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die!
Oh my
god, it's up to Hiro.
It's up to Hiro We don't have to dodge it
They're dead.
Oh my god, you're dead.
They don't they don't hear you the dead don't die
Shadding I was waiting for a monster to come in and just hit
them I got hit I got picked up I I laughed at Natchan.
I laughed at Natchan getting picked up by the monster and
then I got picked up Yeah, and when you got picked up and
they told um, he told you to me I thought it was so funny
and then I died Oh,
do we have enough film because I can dance I had dance to
oh, no film okay all right we need money we have zero views
we need money
she has it she has it nice nice nice we're doing it nice
okay okay i got it let's watch Who first?
Who first?
The first CD.
Film, film, film.
Okay.
Look at this.
It's so beautiful.
This is one Aka Supa.
Have you ever seen this?
This is Doki Spon.
What the fuck?
This is today, this is today.
I said, I said, wait for here.
Oh, this one is so...
Oh my god, oh my god, 35k views!
Look at all the views!
Oh my god!
Oh
My god, it's okay.
We're still alive.
You don't have to cry anymore Oh, we got four hundred
dollars $100 Okay, go next Okay, next Next Oh
Oh, what's this?
Wait, what is that?
Do you want me?
Oh here is very clumsy The comment Look at this This is
doggy This is me Everything is done.
Everything is me.
Oh,
is this where he died?
Is this where he died?
Oh my god.
This is where he died.
Look at the view.
Look at that.
It's because Hiro died.
He died so then we got so much views!
A lot of views!
We did it.
Oh my god, we're doing so well guys.
I always believed in us.
Now I'm happy again.
Look at that.
Now I'm happy.
Damn!
We're so fucking good at this.
Hiro died so the channel can live
She died for our sins guys She died for our sins Now i'm
happy now because we're making money Yeah we have one
thousand oh my god guys guys guys guys i'm going guys guys
Guys guys
This is it.
We saved for this.
Guys, this is it, guys.
We saved for this emote.
And I think Nachan should have it.
Nachan, you should have this.
Wait, wait, Nachan, Nachan, take this.
Thank you!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, use it.
Yeah.
T, T, T, T, T.
T.
Oh my god you're so cool that's right you're so cool You're
so cool Do we need a flashlight?
I think
Do you want to try one long flashlight?
Yeah, we should try one.
Wait, do we have enough?
We don't have enough.
We don't have enough for a long flashlight.
Oh, wait, wait, we do.
Okay, oh, flash this one.
Yeah, we can get it.
What's this?
Guys, I have a flare.
Emergency only.
All right, did you buy the flashlight?
Yeah, and I'm going to buy one.
One blue ball.
I'll kill.
Whoa!
Whoa, who taught you that?
Hiro, what did you teach her?
She told me!
She said that to me!
Wait, long flashlight.
It's long flashlight.
It's long.
It's actually long.
Are you good?
Are you good to go?
Alright.
Yeah.
Okay.
We already did it.
We already made money.
Do you have first life?
No, no, no, no.
Okay, I will give you here.
Use this one.
Okay, I'll defib.
Do you guys trust me?
You guys?
You all trust me, right?
You guys all trust me, right?
Alright.
Okay.
recharged it okay all right i believe in your content
oh hey there's already chorby good content one akasupa all
right so now this is this is two akasupas now this is two
we're more famous so we can charge more so this two akasupa
like and subscribe
demand we're famous now we can charge more supply and demand
okay down we go we need to find new monsters oh there's a
skull here yeah there's a laser kill Can we walk through it?
Oh, I don't think we can.
Wait, wait.
I think I can.
Watch this.
Guys, guys.
Watch this, guys.
Okay, wait.
Someone picked this up.
Okay, watch this, guys.
Watch.
Okay, film me, film me, film me.
I'm not filming.
Filming?
Are you filming?
Okay.
Oh!
That's right.
Wow!
Damn!
Okay, over five we're fine walk around walk around walk walk
walk walk walk Oh God Is she at the hug?
Oh no, she didn't Is she okay?
Are you okay?
That's how you okay.
Oh, I got you You're okay.
You're okay.
I saved you
You're a hug hug hug hug Are you okay?
Okay, we're with Dino.
Dino are you alive?
Okay, we only have one revive
Okay, we did it.
Okay.
Okay, let's go.
I took the flame.
Yeah, I flamed the dog.
Okay, okay.
Let's go.
Let's find the other.
There's another exit, right?
Another entrance.
Let's go do the other one.
Let's see.
A hero died for content.
She died for content.
Like you...
Try.
You tried, definitely.
Yeah Goodbye, you know, go to the slime, you know, go to the
slime, you know, goodbye, you know, goodbye
Hey Maybe she's still here Guys, I don't think Hiro's alive
anymore
Where the hero, where is Hiro's body?
She, she got kidnapped.
Yeah, she got kidnapped.
Oh, Hiro's, oh, there she is.
Oh my god.
What's your HP?
Oh my god, she did.
Hiro's alive.
We're gonna go back to our basement, guys.
We should see if there's a big monster.
I'm pretty sure big monsters might show up let's go to the
other entrance oh yeah where are you guys oh i hear the
slime oh yeah hug hug hug time yeah zero percent okay okay
let's go home then yeah yeah yeah home time let's go home
first oh goodbye guys i don't think Hiro got kidnapped.
Not Chad, where's Hiro?
Hiro?
Is Hiro dead?
Maybe.
Did she die?
I think we should go back.
I think Ditto's dead.
Ditto?
Oh, Dino's alive, Dino's alive!
Dino, there she is, there she is!
Oh, Hira's alive!
You need a hug?
I watch.
I'm gonna watch.
Alright, okay, let's go home, let's go home.
No one's dead!
It's still alive!
She's still alive!
She did it!
I always believed in Nihiro, I knew you would never die.
Yeah, heroes never die.
Heroes never die.
Yes, yes, no.
Overwatch 2 is gonna be free soon.
What an end.
We should have recorded that.
That was such a good line to end on.
Are we gonna stay the video?
We should sack it.
We have so much, so many views.
Sack it, sack it.
All right.
We end this collab when we die.
Okay?
When we all die.
When we all die, we end.
When we lose our channel, we all end collab.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, this collab doesn't stop until our channel dies.
Just like real streaming.
real streaming good night good night everybody oh my god
325k oh my god that's a lot yeah we could we i don't know i
think we should we should film the next one and then watch
it yeah yeah yeah let's go yeah watch it later i feel like
you should watch it later and then Watch both of them at the
same time.
Alright.
No money time.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's the old party poppy.
I'm gonna buy one old flashlight.
Okay, I'm gonna buy I'm gonna buy this too.
Woo.
My order too.
On your order.
The party poppy.
Whenever somebody dies, I'll pop this.
can I die from this guys guys wow guys guys so what oh
i lived though you lost it you lost it why why why why why
don't you guys this though did you film it though did you
film it i think she filmed you did you at least film it but
i lived i lived though are you not happy that i lived we
can't yeah we can't live life anyway our 300 dollar reward
don't you guys guys but i'm alive live though
nice wait is there any holes here no holes oh head head yeah
yeah whoa guys I can't whoa this makes it scarier yeah yeah
it makes it I can't turn this off by the way guys I can't
turn this off so we're gonna use it forever okay see that
there was a light over there yeah over here oh it's the bar
wait yeah did you film it wait wait wait wait wait wait you
don't have the camera yeah wait who who had the camera um
maybe here or not okay okay i'm gonna go downstairs and i'm
gonna try and get it what I don't have yes I don't have yes
okay okay okay okay okay yeah yeah we're gonna we're still
gonna die regardless are you a full HP not yet okay okay
okay okay okay okay I'm gonna grab the camera remember they
don't remember Okay, my flare ran out.
Remember me, Ditto!
Remember me!
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it,
I got it, I got it, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, film this,
film this.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
wait, no, wait, wait, wait, where did I throw the other
thing?
Wait, did you, did you take the other thing I got?
Okay, okay, I'm, oh, film me, film me, film me, film me,
film me, film me, are you filming?
Okay, yeah.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go,
let's go, let's go, let's go.
No, we don't because I No, I don't We gotta go Okay Where's
the two?
How much more film?
Wait, how much film do we have left?
No Um, 63 Okay, okay, stay here, stay here Okay, listen Stay
here and we film Okay, we film Okay, okay, okay Okay, okay
Hello guys Um, we lost two people But it was so cool It was
so funny.
Okay, stop the film.
I got an idea.
Stop the film.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going to do something stupid.
Okay, watch this.
Okay, stay in here.
Stay in here.
Okay?
Uh-huh.
Alright, okay, the splashlight's more expensive.
I'm going to keep this.
We're going to keep this.
Okay.
Wait, let me throw away the...
Okay, there.
Alright, stay in here.
I'm going to bring them to me.
Okay, I'm going to bring them to me.
Close the door.
When I say close the door, close the door.
Okay, I'm going to be a hero.
I'm gonna be a hero for content.
I'm so good at content.
Okay, he was right here.
There's no...
Is he coming over?
Is he...
Is that him?
Open it!
Open it up!
Where?
Found!
Conze!
Found God's side!
God's side!
Oh my god!
What are you doing?
Why did you run at it?
Call me!
We got the content!
We got it!
It's like one shot.
I know!
He caught it too!
And you just died!
One shot!
Oh my god, that's so scary!
That was so scary!
The titan was so scary!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh my god!
That was so scary!
We're gonna pay two!
Alright, here we go.
Thank you!
Oh, it's this one!
Yeah.
E.
T, T, T, T.
What?
A lovely gesture.
Oh, hey, there's already Chorby!
One Akasupa!
Alright, so now this is...
This is two Akasupas now.
We're more famous, so we can charge more.
This is two Akasupas.
Wow.
Yes, go.
Guys, watch.
Okay, film me, film me, film me.
Go flame it.
Filming, are you filming?
Yeah.
Whoa!
Why?
Good job, Hiro.
Good job.
Oh my god, 76, 77 views.
79, it's going higher.
Okay, okay.
Let's go, go, go.
Goodbye, Hiro.
It's an HD.
He was still alive.
Oh my god, she did hit us alive.
Nice.
90!
You got 90 views.
Okay, the next one!
Alright, I think this one would be pretty good.
If somebody dies, I'll pop this.
Yay!
There was a light over there!
What you think I got?
Okay, okay.
I'm filming.
Oh, filming, filming, filming, filming, filming!
Are you filming?
We lost two people.
But it was so cool, though.
It was so funny.
Yeah Okay, stop the film I got an idea I got an idea I got
an idea In here Alright, okay The splashlight's more
expensive I'm gonna keep I'm gonna keep this Okay Wait Let
me throw away the Okay, there Alright, stay here I'm gonna
bring them to me Okay, I'm gonna bring them to me Close the
door Why are they closing
okay Oh my god Wait, that's all you got That's all you got
I'm the monster!
I'm...
I'm not...
What the...
I have to run away!
What the fuck?
What is that?
Excuse me!
I'm really...
I'm flaming!
Oh my god!
It's fine, you guys!
I have to leave it.
What the fuck?
We did it.
Natchan!
Come on, film turn them.
Okay, Natchan, yeah, Natchan, you'll be the film.
Okay, we got, let's buy the deep film.
Wait, we need to revive.
Yeah, we need to revive.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry, I got the revive.
I can't believe it.
I got one second.
Content from that I can't believe it did it only filled one
second I can't believe it did I risk my life for that guy
Whoa!
What is this?
Oh, this is scary.
I've never seen this before.
Oh my god.
Maybe this is...
Yeah, this has to be new, right?
No, no, no.
It's in the middle.
Oh.
Oh, it's over here.
We can go down.
Oh.
Let's do it.
I'm not scared.
This is not... This is for the...
Oh It's the baker.
It's the baker Film it film it film it Guys guys guys watch
God guys guys guys I might be dead Guys okay okay okay guys
Guys I can't get to you I need hugs guys I need hugs I need
hugs Oh my god Hug me Hug me Hug me, hug me!
Where's the hug?
Okay, okay, hug.
Hug all of us, hug all of us.
Hug, hug,
hug.
Wait, is Hero dead?
Oh my god, I'm dead!
Hi!
Hero, bullshit!
Oh my god!
That's so weird.
Last one, last one!
Hey, Dami, hug me, hug me, hug me.
Wait, I don't know if hug me.
What's the hug?
I have another hug.
I have it!
Hug, hug, hug, hug.
Oh my god.
We're all hugged.
Wait, Natcha.
I'm gonna buy her.
I'm fine.
Wait.
Are we all falling?
Okay, I need hugs.
I need hugs.
Natcha's dead.
Can someone hug me?
Guys, I think we hugged too much.
Yeah, yeah, I need a hug.
Okay, I don't have...
I don't have...
Okay, I can hug.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'll be.
I'll be.
All right.
Oh, okay, I'm good, I'm good.
All right, we don't have any more batteries for the DFib.
All right, goodbye.
Wait, wait, wait, we should film the dead body.
Did we film the dead body?
Yeah, I did.
Oh, okay, nice, nice.
Good content.
Do you want a pulse, though?
Okay, okay, okay.
Can I do a pretend?
Pretend, DFib?
Okay, okay.
Is that, okay, are you ready?
Okay, are you filming?
Don't you die on me, not Chen!
She's dead.
There, okay.
all right we're good we need we need to find more monsters
oh yeah no no no no no i see i'm
stuck who's stuck where are you dino do you have the hives
wait did you oh oh she's coming oh she's coming oh i
don't have flashlight anymore dino you're alive You know,
are you alive?
I'm still alive, but I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Do you have the hugs?
Wait, yours?
Oh!
I'm stuck too!
Get off!
Oh, I'm good.
I'm good.
Jump, jump, jump, jump.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna die!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, I kicked you!
Spiders with me!
I'm trying, I'm trying to get over here.
Oh!
We're slowly watching.
Are you filming this?
Film this Hero, film your dying Film it, film it, film it
Hero,
leave?
Leave, leave, you know,
leave Leave, just go home, go home.
Put flashlight here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got it, I got it.
Okay, do you need hugs, do you need hugs?
No.
How much film do you have left?
This is not our home.
Wait, we can fight it, we can fight it.
We'll walk around.
Wait, I think it was the cars.
How much film do you have left?
A 31%.
Okay, we go around.
We go.
I'm pretty sure we can go around here, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe.
It has to be, like, here somewhere.
Oh, no.
I don't think so.
I think I need to go.
Woo!
Okay.
All right, we split up!
Hiro!
Oh, no.
Down is up.
Doki, down is up.
You're so good at that.
Down is up.
Oh, no.
I can't hug myself.
It's so over.
so over.
I don't know where to go.
Where do we go?
Down is not up.
Oh, Hino, he's still alive!
Hino?
Oh, oh.
Oh my god, Hino.
Holy shit.
How do we get home?
How the fuck do we get home?
Oh, he's a little screamy guy!
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Where is home?
What's...
Oh, God.
Oh,
God.
Oh, here!
Oh, you know what?
Oh, we're so smart.
Oh, my God.
The spider followed me all the way to the ship.
Jesus, crazy.
Okay, wait, wait.
We stay here.
How much film do you have left?
I have 18%.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to hug you.
a little bit okay okay we're gonna i'm gonna lead them okay
okay you hug me and then like we're gonna i'm gonna you hug
me and then i'm gonna do it for content how much person i
have 16 okay are you ready to film please film more than
ditto please film more than ditto okay okay okay okay all
right okay okay okay i'm gonna drop the flashlight all right
here you go hello hello i'm I'll do this for content.
Where are the monsters?
Oh, now all the monsters stop fucking trying to kill me.
Oh, wow.
The one time.
Hello?
I hear him.
Oh.
Oh!
Hello?
I'm right here.
What?
AHHHHH!
Oh, I messed up!
No!
Guys, I didn't mean it.
It's so weird.
I don't think she is.
I'm dead?
I'm dead.
It's okay.
I threw everything away.
I threw everything.
I sacrificed myself for content.
For content.
Oh my god.
I saw all of them.
Look, I he hit me into the fucking tongue Oh, hey parkour
you got the town I got tongueed I died for content nice.
All right, let's check how many views we get How many views
did we get?
Okay, we're watching time
I need hugs, guys!
I need hugs!
Okay, are you filming?
Don't you die, I made that chance!
That spider!
The spider was so scary!
Don't have fun with me!
Oh my god.
I can't get all of that.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, you know.
That's such good filming Oh my god 200 Holy shit Oh my god
We did it That was great I feel like Hiro Hiro has been the
best filmer Of all of us She peaks cinema Ashley movie
director V-log What?
What's this?
You're gonna be, she's gonna be the new Paul brothers.
Yeah.
The spider gave us a lot.
She is the best film director from all of us.
Actually, a good film.
Can we ever lose?
We're so good at this game.
We're never gonna lose.
We can get a million views.
I feel like we can, yeah.
Alright, we have, how much money?
We have, like, $900.
Is there anything else we should get?
Wow.
I think...
Okay, I need another flashlight.
Yeah.
Or another DeFiip or Hugger.
Wait, do we...
Who has the Hugger and DeFi?
I have...
I have Hugger.
Oh, okay.
I have, I have Revive.
I don't think we need, like, more than one.
I just need a flashlight.
That's all I need.
Wait, wait, wait.
Do we need the Levi's?
One more?
No, I think we're fine.
I think hugger might...
I think hugging is much more important than defib, right?
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
We gotta save the homie with the hugs.
Wait, we should get taser.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
How much money do we have?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll beat DPS.
Yes.
Okay, okay.
You got to film this, though.
Watch.
Wow.
Oh, God.
What is this?
Watch.
Okay, wait, wait.
Who's filming?
What is the film?
Wait, it's in the ground.
Wait, who's filming?
Who has camera?
Okay, are you ready?
Are you filming?
Yeah, I'm filming.
Okay, watch this.
What?
Wipe you!
You said you wanted to know!
Do it again!
Okay, you do it again?
Yeah!
You wanted to know what it was!
Alright.
Are you ready?
Last day.
What should we get?
Flashlight?
get or emotes we all have an emote i have only one emotes we
we can all only have one emotes we can't like uh overlap it
yeah are you all ready let's go um yoga yoga yoga yeah yeah
yeah let's see What is her emote?
I wanna see.
We need to emote on the monsters.
Oh, true, true.
Oh, when I zap them, we emote.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is good.
Alright, alright, let's go, let's go.
We got this.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll get our first million views
What?
What is this?
Oh!
Film, film, film, film, film, film!
Oh, he's falling, he fell, he fell!
Oh my god.
He's dead.
He's a...
He's...
He's a gay thing.
Nice.
Look at us.
We're so good.
Rest in peace, spider.
Okay, we gotta find somebody I can zap.
It's so...
It's him!
Take a picture!
No, I'll film him!
Wait, you have to be okay, okay!
Okay!
Oh, okay!
I have no more zap!
I'm hugging!
I don't think...
I'm hugging the monster!
I can hug you!
Goodbye now, Chad.
Can you hug me?
Where is it?
You guys hug each other!
Okay!
Oh, wait!
That's nice!
Being hugged.
I feel like, yeah, you should be.
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Okay, happy.
Thank you.
I have 50%.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah.
I can hug while being hugged.
Guys, I don't have a zap anymore.
What?
He's scared.
Just run, just run, just run, just run.
Just run.
Are you sure?
Are you sure you're fine?
He's on me.
He's coming back.
Oh no.
Go.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Are they still hugging?
Are they okay?
I don't know.
I don't care, someone hugged me.
Hugged each other, hugged each other.
Alright,
let's go down, let's go downstairs.
Let's go downstairs.
We need more content.
Let's go this way.
The guy is always here.
Yeah, but he's not here though, so we should be fine, right?
See?
Oh.
I'm lost here.
That's a lot.
If we have two hugger, that's a lot.
That's so good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two hugs is actually really good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
Oh, I found the way.
I found the way.
Right here.
Wait, what is here?
Oh, it's death.
Wait, can I land here?
Can I land there?
Yes, guys, guys.
Guys, guys, come over here, come guys, guys!
Hello?
Guys, watch this.
Okay, guys.
If this works, it's gonna be so fucking cool.
Okay, I shouldn't.
Hello?
Hello, guys?
They're dead?
Revive.
Oh, no.
I know who killed them.
Oh, my God.
Did you revive them?
They're right behind me.
He's right behind me.
Oh, oh, are you guys okay?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh
Can you hug you hug I can't help you there's two of them
there's two of them
There's two of them Guys, I need the hug too I need the hug
I'm right here, I'm right here behind you guys Hug me, hug
me, hug me Okay You hug me, I can film I can film them if he
comes over Oh fuck, fuck Okay, okay, I have a cool film idea
Okay, okay, okay The killer, the killer.
Here.
Careful, careful.
We're just dying.
Oh, God.
There's a- there's an explode!
There's exploding!
Oh.
We're fine.
We're not fine.
Are they- Is he still there?
He's still there.
Okay.
Ditto, are you alive, Ditto?
I don't think...
Wait, I'm gonna check.
I'm gonna check the distance.
Let's see.
Yeah, no, they're dead.
They're definitely dead.
Yeah, we're coming, coming, coming!
Okay, okay, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna film.
Okay, drop your stuff, drop your stuff down there.
Okay.
Alia, where is he?
He's right in front of us.
I think he left.
Okay, okay, you want to film something really cool?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna throw away stuff.
Okay, I'm gonna throw away stuff and then we're gonna film
something really cool.
Okay.
all right okay okay pick there's a camera oh one second okay
okay what i couldn't revive her i think we left her to dead
too okay okay go with something really sick all right follow
me follow me follow me follow me pick up the camera all
right okay i know where to go follow me it's gonna be so
cool i almost have no go to okay i know i don't worry i know
exactly where to go it's gonna
Wait.
It's okay.
They're not close.
All right, right here.
Oh, they are close.
They are close.
No!
Oh
Wait, I got lost.
Oh, is this?
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Close door.
Oh, yeah.
Oh my god, you're okay.
Are you okay?
Oh, God, you, we're gonna be okay.
Okay.
Alright, I couldn't find the cool thing.
It was gonna be like parkour.
I was gonna parkour.
He was like so close.
He was so close.
I wanted to parkour.
There's a defib and a flashlight inside.
There's a defib and a flashlight in the ship, by the way.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna charge my...
Okay.
No, I couldn't- I couldn't do my parkour.
It was gonna be so cool!
It was gonna be so cool.
Alright.
I'm charging my head thing.
Nice.
Oh yeah, who wants to hug?
I dropped the hug.
Yeah.
If anyone wants it.
Maybe, maybe we have to buy one more hug.
You need one more?
Okay.
i'll buy one more oh we lost one okay yeah we might we need
another hug yeah oh my god see it's so long video oh nice
all right i got it watch it or should we just save it we
should save it we already have the views yeah there's so
many monsters now though yeah because we're we're we're two
good content creators we're just so good you guys you guys
are so good i know we're so good at this So inspired.
Look.
Now I'm so happy.
I want to get 1 million.
1 million views.
Oh my god.
644.
Holy shit.
Is the next one 1 million?
Yeah, I think next one is 1 million.
All right, I believe in that check.
We only have one hug.
I have revive.
We have revive and hug.
Where's my flashlight?
Do you want to buy one more hug?
We don't have money, though.
Do we?
Do we have money for a hug?
Where's my other flashlight?
I have flashlight.
Okay, wait.
Is Hiro okay?
Guys, I think Hiro crashed.
You know?
Oh!
Guys, I think you don't crash!
I just crashed!
You don't crash!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, you crashed?
Goodbye, you don't!
Oh!
Edo!
Oh no You know what I think Oh wait, I invited you guys Oh
wait, do we still have?
Sorry, I forgot it was muted on Discord No, we were like,
where did he go?
I'm sorry Can you invite Ditto?
Oh yeah yeah yeah Let me join off of you Where the fuck are
you?
Can we continue?
Are we still in the same area?
Same level?
Yes Yes, yes, same.
Okay, okay I didn't receive the invite.
You said the invite again?
Oh, no.
I don't have the invite.
Oh, I got it.
I missed on you.
Yay, I got it.
I got it.
I'll invite Natchan again, too.
Okay.
Oh, it's still the same.
It's still the same.
Yeah, yeah.
It's the same.
Totally the same.
Oh, thank God.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was gonna be like, no!
We're okay.
We're okay, guys.
We didn't lose!
You guys...
Wait, do we lose our items?
Our item...
Maybe we lost...
We lost our items!
No, I got one of the... I got the flashlight.
I don't have the shield.
Okay, where is she?
Hmm...
loading.
Oh, loading?
Okay.
Where are the other items?
No!
I lost the shotguns.
Wait, did we actually lose the items?
Yeah, we lost the items!
Wow!
Oh my god, my emote is still here too.
How to dance.
I can still dance.
Are you ready?
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Let's go.
Oh my god, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Oh no.
Guys.
Okay, I got out.
I got out.
Okay, I'm okay.
Do we have, can we afford a hug?
Okay, I bought it.
I bought it.
Okay.
I have the shot stick.
Oh, yeah.
Let me have the shot stick.
I'm gonna shot you every time.
Wait, Minis.
I will save it.
I will shovel it again.
No!
Alright, let's go.
Film!
Film time.
No, we need to go.
Yeah, yeah.
Yay!
One million views.
One million views!
We got this!
I believe!
One million views!
Let's go!
I believe in us.
We can do it for content.
We're so good at this game though.
We're so good!
We're so good at content!
Wait, is this new?
Whoa!
Yeah, this is a weird area.
Wait, where is this?
Yeah.
This looks like a new thing.
Oh, it's here!
Oh, it's this area!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah!
Jump jump time!
Jump!
Yeah!
Oh, there's animal statues!
Look, look, look!
Look!
This is Ditto.
Oh wait!
Look at
her!
What is the funny?
I'm sorry!
I was like, you know, I was like, I don't know.
Filming, filming, filming!
That's the wrong one!
No, no, who has the defam?
Give me the defam.
The defam!
I can't drop the defam.
I can't drop the defam!
I'm trying to defam!
Are you all right?
No!
DOOM!
What did I love!?
What did I love?
We die.
I'm flying!
Hey, I cut!
We're all sick.
DOOM!
We can get the camera.
It's OK, I think we have the camera.
We have the camera.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna go.
He's at one.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
one is a curse if someone um if someone is 14 you have to
you have to give them a bunny bunny one no it was the duck
it was the duck that you picked up bunny but um no it was
the duck statue you picked the wrong statue it was the duck
statue that that you picked the bunny was the curse the
bunny was the curse
We don't have money.
Oh, this is the other video.
We have one.
Okay, okay, okay.
We need money.
Insert it.
I can insert it.
Wait, what?
Let me try.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no.
Take a video.
No!
No, please.
No.
Okay, maybe next day.
Maybe next day.
Okay, maybe.
Next day.
Okay, put it here.
Sleepy.
Who has it?
Oh, I do.
My hand is stuck.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
Okay, oh my god, I'm stuck.
Okay, there you go.
I got it.
Oh, but that was converted a while ago, right?
That one was converted.
No, that was converted yesterday.
That's because we, it's because you crashed.
I don't think it was, it saved the floor to crash at Slio's.
Oh, I know.
Oh, someone said the crash could erase it.
No, did it actually?
Oh, the crash erased.
Oh, it's offline.
It's offline.
I think they can't see it now.
Okay, let's get the, let's get the video camera.
Okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, we have nothing.
It's okay, we'll check again.
We'll check again later.
We just need a big monster.
A big monster and then we'll be famous.
Can I, can I?
Yeah, big monster.
Gotcha.
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, I'll try my best.
Film a good video.
Oh, it's here.
Gambatic!
What?
It's right here, right?
The camera?
Was it here?
Oh, we, um, we can't get it back?
Yay!
Yesterday he played, um, it didn't spawn.
I believe in this.
We can do it.
He's not too far.
Where's the voice that song?
Wait, how do you know where the camera is?
You know?
It's land on here, right?
Oh!
We should have died here, right?
It's land on, I think, I think it's land on.
It's not here.
Where did she die?
I died, like, here.
But it would light up.
It would show the camera.
I think it's the other exit.
Yeah, maybe it's in the other exit.
Let's just explore.
Explore time.
Let's go.
We need to find big monsters.
Natcha's here.
We need to wait for Hiro.
I was like, what do you mean?
She's here.
Wrong cat.
I couldn't see the face.
All right.
There's no monsters.
Oh.
Oh!
The tongue!
Tongue, tongue, tongue!
Goodbye!
Give us camera!
If you die, give us camera!
Alright.
Oh, that's me.
Look at her.
Oh, here!
Oh!
Is she...
Oh shit!
Oh no!
Time to turn the camera!
Nice.
We did it, we did it.
Whoa!
Laser, laser, laser, laser.
We go this way.
Here.
Wait, Hira, where are you?
Wow!
So scared.
Yeah, how come now there's no monster?
What monster is that?
It's a savvy ghost!
We don't have hugs!
She said she said she said she said she said she said she
said she said she said she said she said she said she said
she said she said she said she said This way this way this
way oh no not this way no why you follow me
It's okay.
I'll find a monster.
I'm going to find the other camera.
I'm going to be a hero.
I'm going to be the hero.
What goes down must come up.
I'm going to be the hero, guys.
F.
What's that sound?
Did you guys hear that?
Did you guys hear that sound?
What?
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck was that sound?
You guys heard that, right?
It was like...
Where could the fucking...
Oh my god.
Maybe it's over there.
Maybe the camera's over there.
I'm gonna be a hero.
I'm gonna find the camera.
This is it.
They all laughed at me.
But I'm gonna be a hero.
I'm gonna check if they're still alive.
though.
Oh, they're all dead.
Guys, now we have two cameras.
That's amazing.
There's a thing we did.
We're like pretty dead.
Okay, maybe the camera's here.
The camera has to be...
I'm not gonna be able to find the other camera!
Okay.
has to be down here there's no other way hello the fuck is
that sound I hate it I hate that sound where's the other
camera I
don't like this I can't find the other camera oh where
could the other camera be if i escape we have two missing
cameras okay okay okay okay let me double check all right no
no no still alive she's still alive what is that sound she's
still alive look look look look look 58!
What is that sound?
She live!
We'll watch this.
She's getting closer.
Why is she just going back and forth?
I don't like this.
Oh no.
Zeno!
Listen to my voice!
Why is she stuck between 59 and 58?
She stopped moving.
Ah!
What the...
What the fuck?
Who was that?
Where the fuck was that?
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
Oh my god.
And they died.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna get the views.
Oh my god.
We gotta get a content tomorrow.
What happened?
Did I see...
Did you die?
No.
I was...
I was with heal and she died and I took the camera and yeah,
I was trying to get home Oh my god No, guys We need to have
a really good content We need to get the camera tomorrow We
need to find two cameras I don't think we can play the CD
Because of the crash
Okay, it's okay The last two days We'll have so much content
I believe in us I believe in the last two days guys Last day
last day.
We're gonna find the cameras
Yeah Yeah, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Ready?
I think the day before is camera
No, it's okay.
The last camera we got I believe I I believe.
If Natchan believes in us, I believe.
Natchan believes?
Sorry, believe.
All right, let's go.
We email when we're like back home.
When we're back home, we email.
Nino, where's the camera?
The camera is,
right?
Okay.
Oh, the backflip?
Oh, oh, oh, there's Gary.
It's Gary.
Okay, okay, go, go, go.
Wow, wow, baby.
Look at the baby.
Nice, nice.
The baby doesn't hurt, so you're fine.
I was trying to find a camera, too.
Okay, I found bone.
All right, we should film other stuff too Doki?
Light, light, light.
He doesn't like the light.
No, I mean this orb.
Oh, oh, wait, wait, where did it go?
What happened?
It disappeared in the light.
No, where did, where did Nachana and Ditto go?
They're dead.
What?
What happened?
I'm gonna try.
I'm gonna try again.
Capture their body.
Hey, pulse, pulse.
Oh, no!
Oh!
Wait, I can't jump.
Oh, I'm coming!
Hey!
What the fuck?
He touched me!
Oh, my God!
What the...
Why?
What happened?
It's okay.
Maybe you'll go down.
It'll go back up.
is up the ghost parkour down is up okay i found another i
guess i'll just die forever i hope i hope you don't i hope
you don't
goodbye i hope you don't fucking does this for us.
This did please.
We all did.
Our careers!
Oh my gosh.
Shame!
Oh, thank God.
It was just a bad dream.
Okay, we're still alive.
Oh, GG's.
Even though it was a bad dream.
GG's everybody.
I had a lot of fun.
GG.
Yeah, it'll be fun.
GG's guys.
That was so fun.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
No, wait, you guys are all like good at Apex too, right?
Because Ditto is also Apex Pred.
Yeah!
So we're like, we're all, we're all, we're all Apex gamers.
Yeah, yeah.
Four of us, all four.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, they're masters.
Let's play next time.
Next time.
Yeah, I'll stream snipe you guys.
Yeah, yeah, I'll stream start.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
No, we are not scared of Doki because she's noob.
What?
I...
She's noob.
That is fucked up.
I'm gonna kill you.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm waiting for your steam snipe, okay?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You three queue together?
If you snipe me, I will kill you.
Okay, okay, you three queue together, I'll stream start you
guys.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm a cute skater.
Okay, okay.
I'll kill all of you.
Jee-Jees, guys.
I had lots of fun.
Jee-Jees.
All right, in my stream.
Bye-bye, guys.
I'm going to talk to my chat.
Thank you for joining.
Thank you, guys.
Nice to meet you, guys.
Nice to meet you in that chat.
Nice to meet you.
Okay, guys, Apex, let's play it.
Okay, okay, okay.
I kill you guys in Apex, okay.
Okay.
Okay, bye-bye.
Oh, wait.
Okay, that was fun.
Let me swap real fast.
That was, oh, I had a great time.
I had a great time playing with Ditto, Hiro, and Natchez.
um it was great i hope you guys had a fun time meeting hiro
and nachan um i'm really happy to be able to collab with
them um it's so fun playing content warning for the first
time i can't believe i can't believe i was the last hope and
it got fucking sucked up by the fucking tongue but oh my god
it's been three out i didn't realize we've been playing
content warning for three
But yeah, bro, content warning has to be so hard to audio
balance.
I didn't realize how hard it was to audio balance content
warning.
It was such a, it was so, like the echo.
I wish you could like turn down the echo.
I can't believe it.
You can't turn down the echo for that.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
But it was still really, really, really fun.
I hope your ears are okay, chat.
I hope your ears are okay because that was that was a lot of
screaming
um but thank you all for joining um it was amazing playing
with Jiro Natchan and Yiro I really enjoyed my time with
them um I wanted to I was I'm so tired I'm so tired from
laughing um and everything but it was a great time and oh
you guys had a fun time too uh meeting them for the first
time um my brain is fried right now so i can't form
sentences properly my brain is so fried oh oh a little
update a little update uh i think i was talking to like the
minecraft people um but basically next week we might have
the men the dragoons members minecraft server so they said
around it would be like around next week or like a little
bit after next week so i'm super super excited um to have
the minecraft server soon uh for you dragoons um it's gonna
be members only but i'll be streaming the server itself
public because of the rules you know the minecraft rules um
says that uh you can like you can like stream minecraft and
with a paywall so the server uh to showcase around and then
um um the server itself can only be accessed by members so
uh just so just to let you guys know in advance but i'm
super duper excited because it's going to be like an smp
type deal we're like custom stuff on it anyway guys my brain
is super duper fried so i'm going to call it here everybody
uh as always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and
move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for
me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye